[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich war gerade einkaufen,
habe noch eine Kiste im Auto
und werde jetzt kurz meine Einkäufe verräumen.
Viele von euch fragen schon immer
nach meinem Hauswirtschaftsraum.
Heute ist es so weit!
Heute zeige ich ihn euch.
Ich habe euch ja schon meinen Waschraum gezeigt.
Der ist bei uns oben im Obergeschoss
und der Hauswirtschaftsraum, der ist bei uns hier unten.
Mir war nämlich beim Hausbau ganz wichtig,
dass unser Hauswirtschaftsraum direkt im Erdgeschoss ist
und zwar direkt neben der Garage.
Ich kenne das so aus amerikanischen Filmen,
dass man praktisch mit dem Auto in die Garage reinfährt,
die Einkäufe und Vorräte rausräumt
und dann direkt im Anschluss in die Vorratskammer kommt
und aus der Vorratskammer dann in die Küche kommt.
Ich meine, wir haben ja trotzdem
eine normale Hauseingangstür,
also da vorne,
wo praktisch Gäste eben klingeln können
oder wir reinlaufen,
wenn wir eben nicht mit dem Auto unterwegs sind.
Sind wir ja auch ganz oft.
Aber, wenn ich dann einkaufen bin,
dann möchte ich echt die kürzesten Wege.
Also haben wir unser Haus so konzipiert,
dass es das Haus der kurzen Wege ist.
Und das war sozusagen der Grundriss:
Also die Garage in der Mitte,
auf der linken Seite dann das Studio,
wo wir eben arbeiten,
und auf der rechten Seite dann eben unser Vorratsraum
und anschließend die Küche.
Und diesen Grundriss habe ich
sozusagen Murats Bruder gegeben, dem Behdad,
und der hat daraufhin das komplette Haus drumherum gebaut,
also Wohnzimmer, Büros, Toiletten
und das Obergeschoss.
Also der Grundstein war wirklich
der Hauswirtschaftsraum mit der Küche.
Den zeige ich euch jetzt
und hole noch kurz meine andere Einkaufskiste.
Und dann geht ihr einfach mit.
[Musik]
Warte.
Wir haben jetzt hier das System von Schüller.
Schüller baut nicht nur Küchen,
sondern eben auch Waschräume, Hauswirtschaftsräume.
"Easy & Clean" heißen die.
Und da kann man sich wirklich alles
wunderbar zusammenstellen lassen und planen.
Und es ist einfach superfunktional und praktisch.
Und die gibt es auch in jedem Küchenfachgeschäft.
Also da könnt ihr gern mal schauen.
Hier vorne haben wir auch direkt schon die Tür.
Und bei uns ist es so,
wir haben die Tür ein bisschen andersherum geplant.
Normalerweise plant man die Tür so,
dass, wenn man reingeht, die Tür sich nach innen öffnet.
Man hat dann einen kleinen Nachteil
eben mit dem Verstauen, mit den Schränken hinten dran.
Aber man hat den Vorteil,
wenn man mit schweren Kisten ankommt,
kann man die Tür einfach aufdrücken und reinlaufen.
Wir haben es aber andersrum gemacht,
denn bei uns ist der Gang oft von hier
nach drüben ins Studio.
Das heißt, ich gehe morgens immer schwer bepackt
ins Studio rüber, habe hier meine Kisten
und kann dann hier einfach die Türen aufdrücken
und rüberlaufen.
Also, wenn man gerade baut
und sich den Hauswirtschaftsraum eben an die Garage macht,
kann man das bedenken.
Und ja,
wir haben es, wie gesagt, andersrum gemacht.
Ich würde sagen,
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal einmal komplett durch,
ich zeige euch die Schränke,
zeige, was wir so beachtet haben bei der Planung.
Und was ganz, ganz wichtig ist,
ist, dass ein Hauswirtschaftsraum immer dunkel und kühl ist.
Unser Hauswirtschaftsraum hier,
das ging halt, weil wir neu gebaut haben.
Wenn ihr nicht gerade neu baut
oder gerade gar nicht baut,
dann funktioniert es vielleicht nicht.
Aber, wenn ihr könnt, dann denkt dran.
Wir haben hier auf der Seite die Nordseite.
Das heißt, da kommt nie
eine direkte Sonneneinstrahlung rein.
Und wir haben hier einfach nur Fenster drin
zum Belüften, aber auch für ein bisschen Licht natürlich.
Und das sind aber nur so halbhohe Fenster,
damit ich hier unten zum einen mehr Stauraum habe,
aber zum anderen der Raum eben auch nicht zu hell wird.
Das heißt, dieser Raum ist immer schön dunkel,
kühl und trocken.
Und das ist ganz wichtig,
damit eure Lebensmittel eben auch nicht kaputt gehen.
[Musik]
Die zwei ersten Schränke hier,
die haben nichts mit Lebensmitteln zu tun,
sondern sind eher so meine Putzschränke.
Also hier auf der Seite
habe ich einfach so einen kleinen Organizer.
Da sind die Putzsachen drauf,
ein paar Putztücher unten,
ein Tritt, damit ich eben auch an die oberen Schränke komme.
Hier noch unser Schlauch von der Staubsaugeranlage.
Und hier oben habe ich die Reinigungsmittel.
Und was immer ganz wichtig ist,
was man echt beachten muss:
Reinigungsmittel immer oben lagern,
damit die Kinder nicht drankommen,
Kinder und Haustiere vor allem.
Da unten habe ich nur destilliertes Wasser.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Würde ich normalerweise auch oben lagern,
denn trinken darf man das ja auch nicht.
Aber, wie gesagt, da geht auch jetzt keiner von uns dran.
Hier habe ich einfach an der Seite alles schön organisiert
mit Putztüchern unten
und oben einfach alles beschriftet mit dem Etikettiergerät,
damit auch der Murat weiß
und eben jeder, der hier einfach im Haus ist,
wo die Reinigungsmittel sind.
Ja, deswegen wird hier alles beschriftet.
Da oben habe ich eher so meine Fensterputzsachen,
hier noch den Bodenreiniger,
Regenschirme für draußen.
Und was ich hier oben drin habe,
das ist eigentlich
so ein bisschen Deko für draußen
oder auch für das Wohnzimmer.
Also ich habe da dann im Winter zum Beispiel auch
meine Outdoor-Deko
und jetzt halt so Sachen drin wie Blumentöpfe,
die ich einfach so im Alltag nicht brauche,
aber irgendwie braucht man dann doch
immer einen Stauraum dafür.
Und das lagere ich einfach da oben,
weil ich da wirklich nur so alle drei Monate mal dranmuss.
Und deswegen brauche ich mir unten
nicht den Platz voll machen damit.
Hier haben wir dann so angeschrägte Böden.
Und die sind wirklich perfekt für Wasserkisten.
Also da kommt man dann super dran.
Man muss nicht extra was aufmachen
und hat wirklich alles schön griffbereit.
Und ich finde, es sieht halt trotzdem ordentlich aus.
Und da kann auch ich
als vielleicht nicht so ganz starke Frau
trotzdem die Kisten eben runterheben
oder auch wieder reinheben.
Okay, reinheben ist echt schwer.
Eins, zwei, drei!
Ach!
Das macht normalerweise der Murat.
Warte.
Eins, zwei, drei!
Ich kann das auch allein.
Und hier oben habe ich Platz
für meine Einkaufskörbe und Einkaufskisten.
So.
Und damit nicht alles offen ist,
haben wir auch hier
noch mal Platz für Getränke.
Da war einfach Platz und dann haben wir gesagt:
"Komm, lieber mehr Getränke.
Wir haben lieber mehr auf Vorrat als zu wenig."
Und hier oben die Schränke,
die sind auch alle
voll.
Nicht alle, aber fast alle.
Also da habe ich so,
ja, so Zeug halt drin,
was man immer so nicht wirklich braucht.
Aber man hat es halt trotzdem
und dann ist es halt da oben verstaut.
Aber ich muss echt sagen, ich bin der totale Ausmister.
Also ich bin hier bestimmt jeden Monat
und miste immer Sachen aus.
Alles, was in den drei Monaten nicht gebraucht habe,
landet da oben.
Und was ich dann nicht brauche,
landet einfach bei anderen Menschen.
Ja.
Was haben wir hier noch?
Das ist im Prinzip eigentlich eher so ein Weinregal.
Also hier kann man wirklich
ganz schön Weinflaschen verstauen.
Wir haben da jetzt auch Getränke drin.
Da oben Tabletts.
Und hier unten einfach Platz für meine Kräuter,
die ich selber trockne.
Wir haben ja wirklich einen großen Garten
und ich habe wirklich immer ganz viele Kräuter im Sommer.
Und die dörre ich dann in meinem Dörrautomaten
– den zeige ich euch gleich –
und verpacke dann alles hier.
Und wenn ich noch mehr habe,
dann kann ich das ja auch in die oberen Schränke einräumen.
Denn getrocknete Kräuter sind fünf Jahre haltbar.
Das heißt, da könnt ihr euch wirklich
einen Riesenvorrat anlegen
und die werden einfach nicht schlecht.
Hier unten habe ich dann noch
solche Körbe für Zwiebeln zum Beispiel
oder auch für Kartoffeln.
Die habe ich dann da unten drin.
Hier haben wir noch geschlossene Schränke.
Denn ich finde, man muss nicht alles offen lagern.
Und das meiste soll man ja sowieso
luftdicht und lichtgeschützt lagern.
Und hier oben habe ich einfach Dinge drin
wie Medikamente zum Beispiel,
wo einfach Kinder jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt drankommen sollten.
Und gerade Medikamente,
da weiß ich, dass viele die im Badezimmer lagern.
Aber das Badezimmer ist echt der falsche Platz dafür.
Denn dort ist es einfach zu feucht und zu warm.
Und hier in so einem Hauswirtschaftsraum
– wir haben hier auch nie eine Heizung an.
Wir haben zwar die Leitungen verlegt am Boden,
weil wir nicht wussten.
Weil später nachrüsten ist schwierig.
Aber wir haben sie nie an
und haben auch hier die Fenster immer offen
und eine Belüftungsanlage zum Entfeuchten und zum Belüften.
Und daher sind auch Medikamente
hier eigentlich immer ganz gut aufgehoben.
Und wirklich immer schön weit oben,
dass Kinder nicht drankommen.
Was ich hier dann auch noch habe,
sind einfach Konserven zum Beispiel.
Die lassen sich ja auch wirklich wunderbar
richtig gut und richtig lange aufheben.
Und die habe ich dann einfach sortiert so in Oliven,
hier so ein bisschen Tomatenmark und Paprikamark,
Tomaten aus der Dose.
Alles, was wir einfach häufig konsumieren,
haben wir hier mit drinnen.
Und ich finde es gerade in so Schränken ganz praktisch,
wenn ihr wirklich Auszüge nehmt,
also wirklich Schubladen.
Denn, wenn ihr jetzt nur diese Regalbretter habt,
dann ist es immer ganz schwierig,
da ganz nach hinten ranzukommen.
Und hier könnt ihr die Schubladen komplett ausziehen.
Hier haben wir auch so eine Glasseite.
Das heißt, obwohl die Schublade
mir eigentlich auch schon zu hoch ist,
komme ich eben so ganz gut dran
und sehe auch seitlich ganz gut rein.
Und vor allem haben sie einfach verschiedene Höhen.
Das heißt, hier oben könnte ich jetzt noch
– habe ich ja noch Luft.
Ich könnte entweder noch einen Boden einbauen
– aber ich habe mir gedacht, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal.
Ich brauche den Platz nicht.
Und ich kann hier große Sachen verstauen,
mittelgroße Sachen
und eben auch schön flache Sachen.
[Musik]
Hier hatten wir ja jetzt recht tiefe Schränke,
einfach für den optimalen Stauraum und für viel Stauraum.
Und hier mussten wir jetzt aber schmalere Schränke nehmen,
weil hier eben direkt der Durchgang ist,
also die Tür ist.
Und deswegen haben wir hier diese schmalen Schränke
und dazwischen einfach so einen Apothekerschrank.
Und das ist echt perfekt, weil ich hier den Auszug habe
und gerade so schmale und hohe Sachen
wie eben Flaschen oder auch Mehl
oder andere Lebensmittel einfach optimal verstauen kann.
Man kommt von beiden Seiten gut dran,
kann schön durchgucken
und hat alles schön im Überblick.
Und der Überblick ist auch eigentlich das Wichtigste,
was man in so einem Hauswirtschaftsraum haben sollte.
Denn
– ich werde auch gleich meine Einkäufe verräumen,
dass die da nicht rumstehen.
Denn es ist einfach so:
Wenn ihr im Hauswirtschaftsraum
keinen Überblick über eure Lebensmittel habt,
dann werden sie einfach schlecht,
weil ihr nicht mehr wisst, was ihr denn alles habt.
Deswegen alles schön durchstrukturieren und durchsortieren,
vielleicht auch etikettieren
– muss nicht sein, bei mir schon –
und dann habt ihr einfach den Vorteil,
dass nichts schlecht wird.
Neue Lebensmittel kommen immer nach hinten
und die alten Lebensmittel nach vorne.
Und ich finde es immer ganz optimal,
gerade wenn ihr auch so große Konsumenten seid wie ich,
viel backt und viel kocht,
dass ihr wirklich immer
in einer Reihe praktisch eine Zutat habt,
wenn es natürlich geht vom Platz her,
und dann eben einfach den Überblick habt.
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Reihe Zucker,
eine Reihe Puderzucker,
eine Reihe Würfelzucker und so weiter.
Und als wir in unserer alten Wohnung waren,
hatten wir auch nur einen Vorratsschrank
und das war wirklich
– der Schrank, der war ungefähr so groß,
so einen Meter auf einen 1,50 Meter vielleicht in der Höhe.
Und ich hatte da auch Regalbretter drin
und hatte da auch immer einen schönen Vorrat.
Und
da hatte ich es dann praktisch so,
dass ich dann vorne so zwei Zucker hatte,
hintendran zwei Mehl.
Aber ich wusste immer auf den ersten Blick,
was ich dahabe und was fehlt.
Und das ist eigentlich schon wichtig.
Ja. Hier habe ich jetzt mehr diese offenen Regale.
Das sind Lebensmittel, die ich wirklich ganz häufig brauche,
wie Mehl und Zucker und Kakao, Agar Agar
oder auch mein Vanilleextrakt,
hier vorne die Milch,
wo auch die Kinder ganz gut drankommen,
gerade für das Frühstück, für das Müsli.
Und das sind Dinge, die wollte ich dann
gar nicht hinter verschlossenen Türen haben,
weil das halt auch wieder ein Arbeitsschritt mehr ist,
so einen Schrank aufzumachen, die Schublade zu öffnen.
Und hier kommt man einfach aus der Küche her,
holt sich ein Päckchen Mehl
und ist gleich wieder zurück in der Küche.
Ja.
Was ich hier noch habe, sind einfach Schubladen drunter.
Das sind auch so Organisationssachen wie Etiketten
oder Stifte, Zahnstocher,
einfach so flache Dinge
oder Pflaster,
hier ein Verbandskasten
oder auch so ein bisschen Notfallhilfe
wie so Desinfektionsspray für Wunden.
Da kommt man immer schnell dran.
Und da unten habe ich im Prinzip
nur noch Platz für so sperrige Sachen wie
Brotdosen oder einfach Kuchendosen.
So, jetzt verräume ich kurz meine Lebensmittel.
Sonst sind sie nicht richtig gelagert.
[Musik]
Also der Einkauf heute war
so ein Einwocheneinkauf.
Ach, ich war unterwegs und wusste auch nicht,
ob ich alles dahabe oder nicht.
Keine Einkaufsliste geführt.
Hier habe ich das Ganze so ein bisschen unterteilt.
Oben habe ich eben, wie gesagt,
die Tomatenprodukte und so Herzhaftes
und unten eher die süßen Sachen zum Backen,
also so eingelegtes Obst.
Und das hält sich halt echt lange.
Und wenn ich dann mal was backen will
und kein frisches Obst dahabe oder gefrorenes Obst
oder einfach Lust auf Mandarinen aus der Dose habe,
dann nehme ich die.
Und das ist echt immer gut.
Dann habe ich hier drüben
so meine Nudelvorräte.
Und nein, ich bin nicht der Nudelhamstereinkäufer!
Ich war nicht dafür verantwortlich,
dass die Nudeln leer waren.
Wir haben einfach immer Nudeln da.
Und ich steige auch momentan, muss ich sagen,
auf Vollkornnudeln über, weil ich die echt lecker finde.
Und sie sind einfach ein bisschen gesünder.
Und gerade bei Nudeln ist es auch so,
die haben zwar auch ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum,
aber es wird da auch gerade diskutiert,
ob man das nicht einfach streicht.
Denn Nudeln, gerade wenn sie aus Hartweizengrieß sind
und ohne Ei sind,
sind eigentlich fast ewig haltbar,
also 20, 30 Jahre locker.
Die können echt nicht schlecht werden.
Und deswegen haltet sie einfach
oder lagert sie einfach trocken und kühl.
Und dann passiert da echt nichts.
Und dann habt ihr immer was da zum Essen.
Okay, ich habe noch mal Nudeln.
Ich will nur eins dazu sagen:
Dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert,
von keinem Hersteller, den ihr hier
in diesem Video seht.
Also es ist wirklich
einfach nur, weil ihr nachgefragt habt.
Keiner dieser Hersteller
oder dieser Möbel oder egal was
ist Sponsor dieses Videos.
Okay?
Weil sonst hätte ich jetzt alles abkleben müssen.
Ich meine, das ist halt auch nicht Sinn der Sache.
Ich habe es halt eingekauft.
Was habe ich noch?
Da-de-di-dee!
Kühlung habe ich nur das hier.
Und hier haben wir
einen Kühlschrank.
Also ich zeige euch ja auch gleich den Durchgang zur Küche.
Wir haben in der Küche so einen etwas kleineren Kühlschrank
und hier einfach noch mal einen Kühlschrank für Vorräte,
weil...
Ja, der Kühlschrank drinnen reicht einfach nicht
und hier habe ich dann auch mal
so was wie eine angeschnittene Wassermelone,
weil es im anderen Kühlschrank nicht ausreicht.
Noch ein Gefrierschrank.
Und die größten Vorräte habe ich eigentlich immer vorne,
weil wir einfach viel
für euch kochen und backen, für die Videos.
Und deswegen habe ich das meiste
in der großen Küche im Studio,
aber hier auch immer so einen ganz gesunden Vorrat
für unter der Woche und für das Wochenende.
Ja.
Und den liebe ich auch, weil er einfach so schön ist
und diese Wechselfront hat.
Ja, da kann man die Farbe wechseln.
Was ich auch immer gern dahabe, sind so trockene Brote,
so was wie Knäckebrot,
weil so was einfach auch superlange haltbar ist.
Und wenn wir dann einfach mal kein frisches Brot dahaben,
kann ich das hier lagern
genauso wie so Tortillas.
Die habe ich auch gern da.
Und hier habe ich
– ich zeige euch, glaube ich,
jetzt so direkt einfach die Schubladen.
Hier habe ich auch Schubladensysteme auf der Seite
und eine schöne Arbeitsplatte.
Auf der Arbeitsplatte kann ich nämlich
zum einen meine Einkaufskisten abstellen
und eben verräumen,
aber ich kann auch daran arbeiten.
Das zeige ich euch gleich.
Und hier in den Schubladen
hier habe ich dann so meine Folien und
– oh, das Klebeband!
Das habe ich gestern gesucht.
Mein Gott!
Ich habe vergessen, dass ich das hier hatte.
Mein Klebeband
oder hier auch Bienenwachstücher zum Abdecken.
Und darunter dann in der Zwischenschublade sozusagen
einfach noch mal Backpapiervorräte
und, wie gesagt, das trockene Brot.
Und darunter
habe ich dann so eine Schublade für Reis und Hülsenfrüchte,
als Linsen, Kichererbsen, trockene, Bulgur.
Ja, so die Sachen.
[Musik]
Dann habe ich noch ein paar Gewürze eingekauft.
Und gerade so was wie Salz zum Beispiel
ist einfach auch ewig haltbar.
Und ich finde, gerade Salz
sollte auch kein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum haben.
Ich meine, ich habe hier ein reines,
unraffiniertes Steinsalz aus dem urzeitlichen Zechsteinmeer.
Und hat das Ding ein Mindesthalt-
– also eigentlich dürfte es keines haben.
Doch, es hat!
Es hat ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum.
Aber gerade bei Salz verstehe ich es nicht.
Ich meine, es war Jahrhunderte,
Millionen von Jahren auf irgendeinem Gebirge,
wird dann einfach da abgeerntet und
jetzt kann das Salz froh sein, dass ich es gekauft habe,
damit es nicht schlecht wird,
sozusagen.
Aber es ist einfach
– Salz könnt ihr immer benutzen.
Also es wird nicht schlecht.
Hauptsache, ihr lagert es trocken.
Hier oben habe ich auch
so ein bisschen meine Gewürzvorräte.
Pfefferkörner.
Kurkuma habe ich noch mal mitgenommen,
weil wir ganz oft Kurkuma konsumieren.
Und da habe ich einfach auch immer nur
Sachen auf Vorrat, die ich wirklich benutze.
Und das ist, glaube ich, so das Wichtigste,
was man sich da überlegen muss.
Hier unten sind eher so meine Backvorräte
ein bisschen getrennt, also räumlich getrennt,
weil Gewürze
– wenn ich jetzt da Curry drin habe
und hier unten so was wie Backpulver,
dann nimmt das gerne mal den Geruch an.
Also räumlich trennen voneinander.
Und hier habe ich dann so meine Orangenpasten,
Backpulver, Natron,
alles schön in Schubladen.
Darunter
– okay.
Okay, ich muss eins dazusagen.
Ich backe halt echt viel und
die Abstellkammer hier ist wirklich ziemlich groß.
Man könnte hier noch einiges mehr verstauen,
aber ich habe halt viele Backvorräte.
Ich habe halt immer so zehn Kilo Mandeln da.
Und ja...
Ja.
Ihr kennt meinen Backverbrauch.
Es sieht jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen abnormal aus.
Aber ich habe das auch unterteilt
in Mandeln und Haselnüsse und so weiter.
Von daher...
Mandeln habe ich hier.
Nicht hier.
Dann hier.
Und zack!
[Musik]
Und auch bei Zucker ist es so,
Zucker läuft im Prinzip nie ab.
Zucker ist ja auch ein Konservierungsmittel
für Marmeladen zum Beispiel und für andere Lebensmittel.
Und da könnt ihr euch wirklich auch einen gesunden Vorrat
an Zucker anlegen.
Und ja,
der wird nicht schlecht.
[Musik]
So.
Und mein Obst habe ich immer hier.
Denn Samira und Ela,
die essen total gern viel Obst und Gemüse
und dann können sie eben direkt drangehen,
ohne dass sie an den Kühlschrank ran müssen.
[Musik]
So sieht es dann hier aus,
wenn es auf- und eingeräumt ist.
Und ich liebe meine Arbeitsplatte hier.
Denn ich arbeite hier auch wirklich ganz schön viel.
Und zwar habe ich hier meinen Allesschneider
und meinen Dörrautomaten.
Und wenn ich dann Obst und Gemüse
oder auch Kräuter dörren will,
kann ich das eben schön hier machen.
Hier zubereiten
und hier dann direkt dörren.
Und
wie ich meine Lebensmittel einlege oder dörre,
trockne und haltbar mache,
könnt ihr übrigens in meinem Video nachschauen.
Da habe ich bereits eines gemacht.
Und da bespreche ich genau diese Sachen
wie Schneiden, Trocknen, Dörren, Einlegen,
Säuern, Salzen, Zuckern.
Und da könnt ihr mal schauen,
wie man Lebensmittel länger haltbar macht.
Also, wie gesagt, rechts hier
habe ich meine herzhaften Lebensmittel
wie Bulgur, Reis, Nudeln oder auch Backpapiervorräte.
Hier links habe ich eher so meine Backzutaten und Gewürze.
Und hier in der Mitte war noch Platz.
Und das ist auch
mein Lieblingsschrank eigentlich hier drinnen.
Es ist Platz für Pfandflaschen.
Denn wir haben nicht nur Glasflaschen in Kisten,
die man super verstauen kann,
sondern man hat halt schon immer mal auch eine Dose
oder ein anderes Getränk
und weiß dann immer nicht, wohin mit dem Pfand.
Ich weiß noch, bei meiner Mutter war es immer so,
sie hatte dann so eine Tüte an der Wand,
wo sie alles reingestopft hat.
Aber ich habe gesagt: "Ich will diese Plastikflaschen
und diese PET-Flaschen nicht sehen."
Also haben wir hier einfach so zwei
Säcke drin,
einen für PET-, also so Pfandflaschen
oder auch Pfandgläser wie Joghurtgläser zum Beispiel
und die andere,
diesen anderen Beutel benutzen wir einfach für Glas,
was eben wegkommt.
Wie heißt das?
Glas-
>> JOSH: Einweg?
>> SALLY: So Einweggläser. Genau.
Meinte ich doch.
>> JOSH: Mehrweg, Einweg.
>> SALLY: Mehrweg.
Einweg.
Danke.
In zwei Wörtern erklärt
und Sally hat drei Stunden dafür gebraucht.
Ich sage doch, mein Kopf ist heute Matsch.
Der ist richtig Matsch heute.
Also ich mache es noch mal.
Josh,
Josh würde das jetzt so erklären:
Hier habe ich eine Schublade unter meiner Arbeitsplatte.
Und ein Sack ist hier für Mehrwegflaschen
und ein Sack für Einwegflaschen.
In der Kürze liegt die Würze.
Ja, aber ich habe was vergessen.
Und zwar kannst du ja diese Säcke
einfach dann mitnehmen,
– ta-daa! –
dein Pfand wegbringen,
das Geld einkassieren,
was Neues davon kaufen
und später wieder hier einsetzen.
Und das ist ja der Trick dran,
dass du praktisch keine extra Tüten dafür brauchst
und wirklich alles schön sauber verstaut ist.
Und die Taschen, die kann man auch auswaschen.
Also, falls wirklich mal was ausläuft
und es hier drin dann riecht,
dann wäscht man sie einfach kurz aus,
lässt sie trocknen und setzt sie wieder ein.
Und was ich euch hier zeigen muss
und das ist wirklich der Oberhammer
– Murat verkauft es immer als seine Idee,
aber es war meine Idee.
Denn ich habe hier den direkten Durchgang
[Musik]
zur Küche!
Und dann ist es so, als würde man
aus dem Küchenschrank rauskommen.
Cool, oder?
Und eigentlich war hier nämlich
sozusagen eine ganz normale Tür
und ich habe dann unserem Küchenbauer, also der Claudia,
gesagt, ich hätte das gerne als Küchenfront.
Und so ist die Tür einfach wunderbar versteckt.
Man sieht sie nicht, sie stört nicht
und ich habe sie trotzdem da.
War meine Idee, Murat, nicht deine!
Er verkauft sie immer als sein.
Aber kommt. Wir gehen wieder weiter.
Und dann habe ich im Prinzip einfach noch links vom Fenster
nur noch diese Schränke.
"Nur noch" ist gut.
Denn da habe ich auch noch mal so acht Quadratmeter
– Kubikmeter Raum.
War das der Murat?
Na ja.
Und hier habe ich...
Es war der Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Lasst euch aber nicht stören.
Spielt einfach weiter.
Ich räume die Bude solange auf.
Macht euch keine Gedanken.
>> SALLY: Kannst du wischen?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich wische gleich.
Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Und hier habe ich meine Marmeladen drin
oder so was wie
– o mein Gott!
Josh, es war doch noch nicht leer.
Ich verstecke es schnell wieder.
>> JOSH: Es gibt noch?
>> SALLY: Ja, es gibt noch.
Marmeladen habe ich hier drinnen.
Dann habe ich hier Vorräte für Kindersnacks.
Also wir haben halt immer mal
so kleine Frucht-Quetschies da.
Hier unten wäre eigentlich Platz für Abfall.
Aber ich habe halt gesagt:
"Ich will hier im Raum kein Waschbecken haben
und auch keinen Mülleimer haben."
Denn alles, was man hat, muss man halt auch pflegen.
Das heißt für mich,
ich müsste noch ein Waschbecken putzen jeden Tag.
Und da habe ich echt keine Lust drauf.
Also haben wir hier kein Waschbecken.
Und vor allem ist ja der Weg zur Küche wirklich
– also sind wir mal ehrlich, das sind zwei Meter.
Und einen Mülleimer wollte ich hier auch nicht.
Denn ich trage einfach alles dann in die Küche.
Und hier habe ich einfach
alle Tüten, die sich so
in unserem Leben angesammelt haben.
Ich glaube, so eine Tütenbox hat jeder.
Und hier habe ich auch einfach noch mal so trockene Vorräte,
eher so Müsli und Frühstückssachen.
Die sind dann hier.
Da kommen auch die Kids ganz gut dran.
So ein bisschen Amarant und getrocknetes Obst.
Da unten
– es ist eigentlich ein blöder Platz dafür,
denn Ela geht da gerne mal dran, wenn sie drandenkt –
da sind so was wie Marshmallows oder Baiser-Drops
oder Kekse, die ich zum Backen benutze.
Da muss ich vielleicht den Platz noch mal ändern.
Denn die Kleine, die findet echt alles.
Hier haben wir noch so Tee drinnen.
Herzhafte Snacks.
Und dann ganz wichtig:
Süße Snacks hier oben,
damit sie da eben nicht so oft drangehen.
Da komm ich dann wirklich gut dran.
Der Murat leider auch.
Ist auch nicht immer so gut.
Aber so ist es halt.
Und, weil wir wirklich gar keinen Platz verschenkt haben,
sind sogar hier außen
– das sind keine Blenden,
sondern es sind auch
Schränke.
Und da ist
– oh!
Komm, guck mal rein!
Komm!
Ich habe meine Kerzen verstaut
farblich sortiert.
>> JOSH: Natürlich.
>> SALLY: Schön!
Schön, oder?
Ja. Und selbst da oben ist noch ein Schrank.
O mein Gott! Da sind die BVB-Dinger drin vom Murat.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder,
warum ich sie da rein habe.
Was habe ich hier?
Oh, noch mal Oreo-Vorräte und Kekse,
die ich zum Backen benutze.
Und, damit sie keiner aufisst, habe ich sie da hoch.
Denn da komme nur ich ran.
Okay, und der Josh.
[Musik]
Also das war jetzt so unser Hauswirtschaftsraum.
Was ich, glaube ich, noch erzählen...
>> MURAT: Ich brauche Reinigungsmittel.
>> SALLY: Bist du bald fertig?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, hole dir einfach.
Murat! Nee, nee, nee, nee!
Bist du das immer, der das macht?
>> MURAT: Was?
>> SALLY: Ich habe doch extra hier die Sachen
– guck – beschriftet.
Outdoor, das muss hier bleiben.
Spüli ist eine Reihe hier.
So.
Und dann ist hier eine Reihe Bodenreiniger.
Jetzt ist hier ein Backofenreiniger.
Ach Murat!
Kannst du das später bitte wieder sortieren?
>> MURAT: Ja. Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Nee, nee, nee!
Nicht tschüss! Später...
>> MURAT: Ich mache das! Ich mache das!
Ich muss aufräumen.
>> JOSH: Okay, nächster Versuch.
>> SALLY: Nächster Versuch.
Also das war jetzt unser Hauswirtschaftsraum,
eine Roomtour durch den Hauswirtschaftsraum sozusagen.
Und was wirklich ganz, ganz wichtig ist
und es ist, glaube ich, die wichtigste Info:
Alles was ihr hoch oben lagern müsst,
sind so Dinge wie Medikamente,
Alkohol,
Süßigkeiten
und Putzmittel.
Da sollten nämlich kleine Kinder
und kleine Männer nicht drankommen.
Und etwas noch zum Thema Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum:
Also kauft eure Lebensmittel wirklich immer mit Bedacht.
Kauft nur auf Vorrat ein, was ihr auch wirklich oft verwendet.
Wenn ihr Lebensmittel frisch ausprobiert
und einfach mal was testen wollt,
lieber nur ein Päckchen kaufen
und schauen, ob es euch eben gut schmeckt.
Und wirklich nur das lagern, was häufig verzehrt wird.
Und dann gibt es eben Lebensmittel,
die trotz des Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatums,
was vielleicht abgelaufen ist, trotzdem noch haltbar sind.
Da kann ich euch so eine kleine Übersicht geben.
Ihr könnt euch im Prinzip merken,
dass abgepacktes Brot bis zu acht Wochen haltbar ist,
Säfte in PET-Flaschen ungefähr zwei bis drei Monate,
Säfte im Tetra Pak aber bis zu sechs Monate
und Säfte im Glas sogar bis zu einem Jahr haltbar sind.
Getrocknete Kräuter und Gewürze
sind vier bis fünf Jahre haltbar,
Nudeln ohne Ei sogar mehrere Jahre,
Reis, wenn es ein Vollkorn- oder Naturreis ist,
bis zu einem Jahr
und, wenn es ein geschälter, weißer Reis ist,
sogar bis zu zwei Jahre,
weil einfach das Fett schon entzogen wurde.
Mehl könnt ihr bis ein Jahr
nach dem Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum benutzen.
Und Milchprodukte, die in den Kühlschrank gehören,
die sind auch mehrere Wochen noch haltbar.
Und pasteurisierte Milchprodukte, wie pasteurisierte Milch,
die ist auch mehrere Monate
nach Haltbarkeitsdatum noch haltbar.
Alles in allem muss man aber dazu sagen,
dass man einfach nach der Nase gehen muss
und auch nach der Optik.
Das heißt, wenn ihr irgendwo auf irgendeinem Lebensmittel
schon Schimmelsporen seht,
sofort wegschmeißen.
Denn der Schimmel, der verbreitet sich auch unsichtbar.
Gerade bei frischen Lebensmitteln
aus dem Kühlschrank ist das wirklich superwichtig.
Und natürlich nach der Nase gehen.
Also, wenn ihr auch an einer Milch riecht
und die riecht einfach schon sauer,
nicht mehr benutzen.
Es kann ja auch sein, dass mal was schlecht geworden ist,
obwohl es noch haltbar ist.
Deswegen immer nach dem Geruchssinn gehen.
Ja. Und das war jetzt unsere Roomtour.
Ich hoffe, ihr konntet euch ein paar Tipps und Tricks abholen.
Das war wirklich auch ein Video,
wonach ganz, ganz viele Menschen gefragt haben.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte all eure Fragen beantworten.
Falls nicht, dann schreibt sie mir gerne.
Und ich freue mich auf euer Feedback
und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste Mal.
Tschüss!
Ich wollte ja eigentlich noch was sagen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich es sagen soll.
Ich habe auch einen Raum mit Einbauschränken.
Also ich habe mir das Video nicht angeschaut,
aber ich weiß, dass jemand ganz viele Einbauschränke hat,
weil es unter meinem Video kommentiert wurde.
Hey, ich habe jetzt auch einen Raum mit Einbauschränken!
Und ich nutze sie.
Wer hat es verstanden?
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, alle.
>> AYLIN: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Tschau!
Also gerade auch jetzt, nicht?
Pandemie hin,
Pandemie her:
Aus Pandemie mache ich ein Panini.
Grüße gehen raus an Teddy Comedy!
Sorry, aber immer, wenn ich jetzt "Pandemie" höre,
muss ich an den Song denken und dann...
Na ja, egal.
[Musik]